this is the Empire State Building with
102 floors it's one of the tallest
buildings in the US but it's four floors
shorter than the MSC Oscar which isn't a
building but a boat the largest
container ship in the world launched in
January 2015 the MSC Oscar is nearly the
size of four football fields laid
end-to-end it has a draught of 16 meters
which means that if you were to stand at
the bottom of the ship he'd be five
stories underwater it's one of 5,000
container ships crossing the world's
oceans carrying the vast majority of
products you buy and the parts those
products were made from these ships are
the engine of the global economy but 60
years ago they didn't even exist how did
all this happen
for hundreds of years shipping was a bit
of a nightmare goods had to be
individually unloaded into storage of
ports then individually packed on the
ships and unpacked afterwards this
process was painfully slow and expensive
and that left items vulnerable to damage
and theft in 1956 Malcolm McLean an
American Trucking executive proved that
you could save time and money by loading
truck containers directly onto ships on
the other side they'd be put back onto
trucks or trains and reach their
destination without ever being opened
MacLean later got the government on
board by using containerized service to
help the military provide supplies for
the Vietnam War problems in Vietnam have
been in the field of containerization
after the industry recognized how
efficient container shipping was the use
of container ships exploded
international standardization was the
key the unit of measurement is TE you
are 20-foot equivalent most containers
used today are twice as long shippers
quickly realized that the larger the
boat the cheaper the shipping price per
container so the size of the larger
ships has grown exponentially in 1999 a
shipping executive predicted an eventual
ceiling of 12,000 tu but the MSC Oscar
has a capacity of over 19,000 to
accommodate these huge ships courts have
been rebuilt with vast yards to store
the containers and huge cranes to load
and unload them simultaneously in a
specific order today's biggest ships are
so huge that they can't actually fit
through the Panama Canal or Dokken and
the American port they're mostly used
for shipping between Europe and Asia
it's hard to overstate how much all this
has transformed the world
me after containerization global trade
and merchandise soared while insurance
costs and inventories decreased jobs at
ports and in factories in the u.s.
dropped while consumers gained access to
a greater variety of goods at a lower
price
as a result products we buy can be made
with parts from several different
countries by people on the other side of
the world and it's hard to imagine any
of this happening without someone first
deciding to put this stuff in a box and
put the box on a boat
[Music]